hey everybody welcome to the first
episode of
2022 and featuring today's guest my
friend carlo rivelli
who's joining us all the way from
toronto in this particular video
and currently i think he's back in
france where he is a renowned professor
and scholar of quantum mechanics and of
the theory of time
space matter energy
and it was a treat to interview him this
uh was again uh something i need to beg
his forbearance and your forbearance an
interview i conducted you know six or
seven months ago
uh by the time you're listening to this
and just had so much cool content to put
out
and needed so much
kind of investment to give this episode
the attention it deserved that it got
delayed
and not the least of which was the
recording that carlo and i have been
doing
since middle of last year in 2021
of galileo galilei's dialogue on the two
chief world systems so look for that
coming extremely soon hopefully in time
for galileo's birthday the first ever
audiobook
ever made of galileo it's kind of
impossible to believe when i first heard
that remarkable stat that no such audio
book existed for the maestro i became
quite enervated and it inspired me to
seek out
and hopefully not destroy this wonderful
manuscript by one of history's greatest
thinkers but also one of history's
greatest writers and carla was the ideal
person to land in the starring role of
saviati the salvation
the chosen one but anyway you'll have to
wait for that that this episode is about
his most recent book helgeland which is
a story of another genius uh in this
case it involves the story of quantum
mechanics and how quantum mechanics came
to dominate what we understand about the
uh about the work
so what is helga land helgeland is a
phenomenal kind of magical quest i call
it a hero's journey it's really tracing
the journey of how werner heisenberg
made critical
understanding of how we could
conceptualize and formalize quantum
mechanics and he did so in contrast as
as most uh as most heroes have to have
there has to be a conflict uh
you know in addition to the to the
protagonist sort of an antagonist and i
wouldn't say that schrodinger is
heisenberg's antagonist but this uh this
story traces this isolation that that um
that heisenberg had to go into in this
isolated treeless island in the north
sea where this young guy who's 23 is the
age of my students
and he set the stage for everything you
know that we do in modern quantum
mechanics is in some sense tracing its
evolution from what uh what was
discovered on helga land this remote
island not lego land we have that here
in california i've made some discoveries
there such as why are legos so much more
painful at night than in the morning
when you step on them but that's for
another subject this topic we talk about
what is a matrix what does it mean to do
matrix mechanics how can we understand
philosophically based on pure math
how can pure math lead us to a
philosophical understanding of the
interpretation of quantum mechanics so i
devoured this book it's got many many
glowing reviews and this book has an
audiobook version which was not read as
his last book the order of time which i
interviewed him about last year by the
time you're listening to this in 2021
um
by uh by benedict cumberbatch there are
no cumberbatches narrating this episode
this particular book
but but better than that we just keep
witnessing the maturation of one of our
greatest current thinkers
who happens to be a great writer as well
and so i couldn't be more pleased that
i'm working together with carlo
and my one of my oldest and best friends
lucio picharillo at the university of
manchester
jim gates at brown university reading
the forward of
galileo's dialogue and also fabiola
giannatti who's reading galileo's own
author's preface to this uh to this
audiobook and then finally uh frank
wilcheck who reads einstein's forward to
the dialogue but anyway you'll have to
wait for that hopefully by february 15th
or so i'm going to launch a new podcast
think like galileo or something like
that or the dialogues hope to have some
great guests on the show as well i'm
going to try for some stretch guests but
definitely try to get on all my fellow
co-authors carlo fabiola luccio jim
gates frank wilczyk and maybe a couple
of surprises because galileo is more
relevant than ever now this book is 390
years old in 2022. so anyway
this book that you're going to hear
about as soon as i stop yammering on
helgeland uh is another book that will
bring to life in a way as uh neil gaiman
wrote his in comium
about it this is the place where science
comes to life where belly is a genius
and an amazing communicator and that's
true and you'll see it in this book we
also have a little a call back to my
episode with uh car with carlos nemesis
perhaps his antagonist michio kaku
past guest on the show when kaku had
some negative things to say about
not about carlo but about loop quantum
gravity which carlo among others have
has done more perhaps to popularize than
any other person so anyway i'll stop
yammering i'll save you the
normal uh spiel about leaving reviews
now you can leave reviews on spotify so
please do that uh if you're listening on
that platform you just leave a rating
you don't even have to write a review
actually
and you can do the same on apple
podcasts and you can also do it on
audible podcasts so i do it on all three
and i would be delighted if you would do
the same and now without further adieu
please enjoy this episode featuring
carlo revelli my friend and co-author or
co-narrator about his wonderful new book
helgoland making sense of the quantum
revolution let's go
[Music]
any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
open the pod bay doors now
[Music]
welcome everybody to a special segment
with professor carlo rivelli who's a
friend a hero an adventurer and an
explorer of mental realms beyond which
many of us can contemplate today he is
coming from the island of heroes the
island of physics which is also
not unrelated to the island that plays a
huge role in his magnificent new opus
he'll golem we'll talk about that in
this segment uh first of all carlo how
are you and where are you my good friend
hi brian it's a great pleasure to be
with you
um i am in a fantastic place i've been a
greek
island
uh in northern
actually it's almost turkey i can see
turkey there from the window
uh called lesbos and lesbos is a magic
place because uh you can say it's the
beginning of poetry in the beginning of
science maybe exaggerating a little bit
uh because here is where suffolk wrote
his poems safo lived and al
two immense greek poets and i'm reading
their poems and they're marvelous but
here is also where aristotle came spent
many years
doing um his biology and um people say
the lesbos is is uh was foreign
um but it's more than that because
aristotle
biology is probably the first
specific detailed campaign of
observational signs
collecting data talking to the fishermen
talking to the people
making
catalogues comparing things
it's really the beginning of observation
science here in this was 25 centuries
ago
that's wonderful and when i think about
greece it's impossible not to think
about the odyssey homer the great heroes
of greek mythology but also as uh as i
think about it uh the role of islands
plays a huge role in science as you say
you mentioned darwin the galapagos
islands we have here in america shelter
island where fine men and many of the
greats would gather in the 40s and 50s
under government security protection
their brains were so valuable that the
military would come with guns carlo to
protect them and of course you mentioned
lesbos where i think aristotle did do
observations i think he was the first in
human history carlo correct if i'm wrong
to determine that whales are mammals and
not fish and he probably did that there
yeah yeah and his science is
extraordinarily good he sort of has a
bad press
as a scientist but he's completely
undeserved he's a man scientist
so uh with the laws of logic and and
just really you know creating some of
these frameworks of course you you've
mentioned in the past and other
conversations we have about anaximander
and others that you regard a similar
status as heroes but i want to talk now
about an island that really is unheard
of until this wonderful new book of
yours helga land came out and that's
helga land island in the north sea which
is a barren tree swept island where a
romantic
tale of a 23 year old went into
seclusion
and came out with some revolutionary new
ideas that upended the orthodoxy of his
time similar to
what darwin did in his heroic voyage and
the beagle talk about this marvelous
island helga land what it means and i'm
curious have you been there
many many years ago and i want to go
back because now after after being
immersed in helgel and thinking for for
so long for writing this book
i definitely want to go back uh this
happened 100 years ago in fact 98 years
ago 97 years ago
and it's really one of the moments
of the great revolutions in science one
of the greatest revolutions in science
some might say the greatest
which is the beginning of quantum theory
it's the beginning of quantum mechanics
not because quantum mechanics was
entirely invented there as the quantum
mechanics came many steps but that
up to that point were the pits bits and
pieces of of new information about the
world that didn't fit together
and this young kid because he was 23
isn't marvellous werner heisenberg
german
uh went to this island that immersed in
his calculations but
really because he was suffering for hay
fever
and the island has no vegetation
so
it was a relief for his allergies
uh and spent uh days and days there and
came out with this incredibly new idea
which was the the turning point
of uh that open up quantum theory in
fact eisenberg is the one who got the
nobel prize he's the only one who got
the nobel prize for the creation of
quantum theory and deservingly so
and the idea was there he was alone
this magic island the the name helgeland
means uh sacred sacred highland
um goethe says is one of the places
where you hear more intense
uh the spirit of nature i don't know if
this is true but certainly it's a
it's a place where
uh i think our
view of the world changed heisenberg
did something completely new and it's
fantastic because we're still immersed
in that revolution right the the quantum
revolution
this for the point of science this is
probably thus the center of the quantum
revolution
like the renaissance was a period of the
copernicus revolution
um
matter is not the same reality is not
the same after the quantum and a century
has passed
but still we're still debating among
ourselves what we really have learned
with quantum physics in spite of the
fact that you know the technology we're
using is quantum physics we understand
um uh the atomic structure with quantum
physics we understand the color of the
sky you understand how the sun works we
send everything with quantum physics
there's never been wrong all the
traditional quantum theory all right we
have no idea where there's the limits of
quantum series so it's the greatest
theory ever in a sense
and yet it's in confusing mysterious and
that's the beauty and it all started to
know this that island
and when i read your words they're so uh
full of poetry and beauty but you also
say in this book that it's a book for
your colleagues and i hope that includes
me because uh it's it's not a simple
book it's not a it's not a dumb down you
never do that you respect your audience
too much and you're rewarded by millions
of fans around the world including
having your books translated more times
and sold more copies than 50 shades of
grey which you know i i was a customer
for both of those books uh in that rare
cohort but uh but carlo you talk in the
book you talk about granularity and you
talk about heisenberg is this link
between the granular between the atomos
between the ancient greek lucretus and
and
latin scholars and i want to know uh
when you when you think about this the
difference between what we can observe
and what really is that really came home
to me for the first time as a
professional physicist in this book that
you know as you say bor you know
einstein used to say god doesn't play
dice bohr said don't tell a god what to
do einstein
but i feel like we kind of sometimes are
guilty
and that we tell the particles what to
do and we tell them they should behave
like little baseballs and so that we can
understand them talk about what this
what heisenberg meant to our
reinterpretation of mechanics as a whole
it's that's you you touch the core
problem because uh um what heisenberg
did exactly in on that island
it's the following um the problem at the
time on the table of the physicist was
how the atom works and and it was
understood roughly that the atom is this
central nucleus that later has been much
better understood around which some
other electrons
but these electrons around the nucleus
like like like planets around the sun
seem to do very strange things they were
only orbiting on some
specific orbits and then jumping from
one orbit to the to the next one orbit
and then i jump down to another orbit
um the famous quantum leaps it says the
first quantum leaps
and nobody understood what kind of force
can move an electron on specific orbits
and and to these jumps or which equation
of motion can do that
and heisman this is complete magic
he said forget the force
forget the equation of motion keep the
equation emotional you had before keep
the force you have before keep the
hamiltonian you have before keep the
description before
change the way
you think about the electron
is not a little particle that jumps it's
something else
what is it
don't ask just ask only what you observe
you don't see the electron because to
see the electron some light should go
from the electron to you
just talk about
the final observation
and this seems against science right i
mean it seems to be
putting in doubt the entire idea that
you describe what happens
out there
you only talk about the observations
and but it works because he used this
mathematics of the observables
and the fantastic works and 100 years
later we all do that i mean every time
we
the the people who design this computer
here uh and and and the hardware
use use the the essentially the
mathematic of heisenberg of what you
observe
and you treat everything like a closed
box you do i do this and observe that i
do this and i observe that
but
what does nature care about who observes
what
right what is the observability here
what is an observer
it's not a piece of nature like any
other
and so today um
everybody uses quantum mechanics in in
in chemistry in astrophysics nuclear
physics
in all sorts of
disciplines
and many people don't ask questions but
those who ask questions what is really
going on between one observation and the
other what happened in between
they split
in various
interpretations of quantum mechanics
which is mean different ways of trying
to make sense of that
and some people
and my book comes right in the middle of
this discussion right and some people
say okay there's things going on there
there's a wave that fills up everything
and then out of the wave in some way we
we have the observation
um
but there is a a different way of doing
that a different camp if you want which
makes the following
uh observation
if
the electron if i see the electron
i am a piece of nature
right you're a piece of nature brian
you're not outside nature uh and whoever
is listening to us
the the the person observing is a piece
of nature it's not outside nature
observing nature
so what quantum mechanics describe is
not
how
a man or what a phd student observes
nature is how nature one piece of nature
affect another piece of nature
so that's the way to think about reality
not how things are not how one thing is
but how two things interact
and the property one thing are the way
it affects the other things
and that's a way of viewing quantum
mechanics called relational quantum
mechanics which i in particular defend
on that book
so out of this mystery or quantum
mechanics so the various ways of trying
to make sense of it
um
i describe in detail this relational
interpretation which tell us that the
world is not made by things with
properties
but by think that interact with one
another and their properties only when
they interact
relations rather than properties things
and properties
and the relations are intimately
connected to observations which again
it's a trivial example but aristotle
made an observation that these fish that
were thought to be fish giant fish are
actually mammals they nurse their young
they have uh lungs and blowholes or
whatever i i'm not a i'm not an
ichthyologist or a paleonologist
studying whales but but one thing that
stood out for me first of all whenever i
see a book nowadays about quantum
mechanical interpretations i had david
kaiser on i we've talked with adam
becker many books sean carroll's been a
guest many times and it's um i always
get this sensation that oh my gosh not
another quantum interpretations book and
that has an acronym i've coined called
nick clab which in arabic means very
wise or learned so i want to salute you
for being a nick club very very wise and
learned but uh when i read about quantum
mechanics i always think um you know are
these kind of how do i translate it into
today's language so today uh there's a
war going on and uh between proponents
of string theory for example uh lying at
the heart of quantum gravity maybe
theories of everything there are
proponents such as yourself elise mullen
and others although we'll talk in a
different segment about how lee is maybe
becoming a little disillusioned uh but
we'll talk about that later but
nevertheless i try to translate it we're
the camps of schrodinger and heisenberg
in opposition uh the same way that
people in string theory like michio kaku
past guest on the show and yourself
might be in opposite camps are you
dueling is it is it kind of that rivalry
that we should think about where there
will be one uh victor or is it not a
zero-sum game where both heisenberg and
schroedinger are correct do you see any
possibility for that to occur in say
strength theory versus with quantum
gravity are you asking about trading
reversal heisenberg were you asking
about loop versus
lupus strings
i want to say is the is the is the
tension between loop quantum gravity and
string theory reminiscent or rhyming
with the history of schrodinger versus
heisenberg those are two diametrically
opposed but ultimately harmonious
relations but is string theory
reconcilable with loop quantum gravity
or is only one theory going to prevail
there'll be an attempt to combine the
two and to see these the two as
different uh
possible different aspects
of of some larger correct theory and i
don't think this is impossible
uh maybe there is a a
a a larger point of view
um because uh in in in loop quantum
gravity does not address the problems
that are addressed by string theory
namely the the unification the idea of
that all the forces should be as aspect
of a single thing
um
so from the point of view quantum
gravity these are not
problems that are addressed so uh i am
i don't have an opinion if you want i
don't know a strong scientific opinion
about those problems
and vice versa from the point of view
string theory in in spite of a lot of
progress recently
i would say that the uh
the the the the real problem with less
than quantum gravity which is understand
the quantum nature of of of space-time
has never been really addressed so far i
mean people talk about that and
recognize it
and christ goes around by putting
theories on the boundaries here with the
bulk and things like that
but
first string theory what happened here
in the very very small of the blank
scale here's the answer
well look group control gravity has an
answer has a tentative answer because we
don't have an experiment yet but there's
an answer there is a very precise theory
of quantum gravity in here in this small
just the quantum aspect of space time so
could it be that there's a larger theory
which is like loop quantum gravity when
you describe space-time and like during
the initiation it could be
but you know brian everything could be
that's not very interesting what could
be it's interesting what we can do
today and i don't think today the
question is what is the ultimate here of
nature i have never been interested in
the ultimate theory of nature i'm
interested in probably one by one
right i mean this is what happened
to black hole at the end of the
operation and i can compute it i am
computing it maybe i'm wrong but i'm
computing it i'm interested to what
happened at super short scale and we are
computing it
uh these are
problems that can be solved on the basis
of our current knowledge general
relativity and quantum mechanics and
that's what loop quantum gravity does
and so when we look at uh the the you
know kind of tension between the
schrodinger interpretation and the
heisenberg interpretation matrix
mechanics wave mechanics you go into
great depth about uh the kind of
beautiful tension between the two but
the ultimate harmony reconciliation and
uh union and sometimes uh of the you
know the school that says shut up and
calculate uh versus those that say you
know we have to obsess about the
interpretations
yeah and then uh but i look at things
like
matrix mechanics in a different light
now and again this book is written not
just for the general public although
anybody with a with an interest and a
time to put it in will appreciate this
delightful book but certainly my
colleagues and i appreciate it because
you make the point that that you know
heisenberg really came out of the the
same milieu of of classical mechanics
poisson brackets hamiltonians and so
forth so i i view it as and you give
this wonderful introduction to
commutation relations so you you show it
on the page here and we'll put the
equation famous i think it's on
heisenberg's tombstone right uh this
equation the commutation relation that
they don't commute that that momentum
and position don't commute um and i
think that is the fundamental essence of
quantum mechanics
and i really appreciate it
after this book but um i want to ask you
the presence of imaginary numbers plays
a much bigger role in quantum mechanics
than classical mechanics it's almost
like we have to translate into the
complex
universe to comprehend it and there's no
surprise that we can't understand it
because we can't visualize what a
quantum now i've always wanted to ask
you this
in um in the wave mechanics of maxwell
there are imaginary numbers and we have
complex numbers how come that is we
don't have books about interpretation of
maxwell's equations uh why is it that
the presence of an imaginary number in
quantum mechanics causes so much more
difficulty for the human brain our
consciousness than the presence of an
imaginary number in a classical
mechanical field like uh
electromagnetism or or regular ordinary
relativity let me let me answer to
various things you have said um brian
first of all thank a lot for what you've
said about uh my book being of interest
to a person like you maybe to a real
scientist not uh i have
a strange experience with my books uh
they are loved more by the extremes
and less by the middle
namely the people who react more with
more excitement by my to my books are
those who know nothing about science
and i have a story which says look this
is interesting because this happened
this happened this happened and as you
say i never try to cheat
but i take away a huge amount of things
i don't talk about that i don't talk
about that about it so just give the
court
and those who know science very well
like you you work with your dirty hands
with science read the book and say ah ah
that's an interesting take on that on on
that so it's it's a perspective this is
interesting by itself in the middle
there are a lot of people who know some
science and uh
look for polarization book for adding
more details and then they get
disappointed because they don't find
what they have studied
and they say oh come on but i studied
the school that this so-and-so and this
book doesn't say that what's the point
okay
so i get the criticism from the middle
and i got the biggest praises from
uh
my grandmother who doesn't know how to
do five times seven and from a nobel
prize who i'm not gonna uh
uh uh name here
uh uh who is an enemy of mine and
uh but but he was excited about the book
so so that's exactly what what what my
books in a sense are different than the
standard the popularization booth yeah
well you know carlo there's a you know
i'm jewish and there's a yiddish proverb
that he who stands in the middle of the
road gets hit by both sides of the
traffic there's probably an expression
too right so you should explo
if it appeals to everybody it appeals to
nobody and i love that about your books
i learn something and every time i read
your book and i brought them up i love
you saying that you're very kind now let
me talk about heisenberg and schrodinger
um
the formalism that they introduced which
are completely different
turn out to be aspect of the same story
that was a remarkable is schrodinger who
realized that first
um so in a sense they were doing the
same mathematics but then the the the
view the the physical interpretation
what was going on completely different
and uh
they thought at the beginning there was
there was a bitter bitter exchange
between
between the two in particular between
the two camps
the the camp which was in
in gertingen
heisenberg but also max bourne jordan
and all those people and to some extent
iraq in the uk
and the schrodinger camp and einstein
was on his side
um
they had a very different view of what
they had discovered
and to some extent we are still there
there are some people who think allah
schroedinger namely is a big wave it's
just everything waving there's no
particle
it's just a wave and the particle for
some strange reason the particle end up
being manifesting with itself as a wave
and that's the the schrodinger company
the heisenberg cup still today
are people which in various ways right
cubies relational quantum mechanics
perspectival views other other
perspective
think no no no no wave the wave is just
you you you you you're doing
calculations there's no wave there there
is a particle
that at some point hits something and
there the particle is no point
and
but
and schrodinger himself which was the
other camp shooting a shifter camp at
the end of his life he said okay i was
wrong
and and and and and and said no no no
an elector is another way it's just as
a particle but not a continuous particle
a set of discrete interactions it's like
snap snap snap snap snap
that's what an electron is
this basic discreteness of the
manifestation bo max born had the same
intuition heisenberg had the same
intuition and i think um many physicists
don't have that intuition today and i
think this is misleading it's much
better to think of quantum mechanics
as
manifestations of one piece of the world
with respect to another piece of the
word instantaneous
so uh
you are
brian
what your the way you affect the world
you are what i see you i am the way i
affect the world an electron is the way
it manifests itself to something else
everything which is is is only because
it's in relation with something else the
world is a it's a network of relations
not an ensemble of things
um
so you see the
in reality has not been resolved
the
the tension between schrodinger and
heisenberg we are still in the middle
of the discussion and bringing argument
to one intuition of the opposite
intuition
but that's great because let me say one
lesson
because you said oh good good
you said why do we i'm so confused about
quantum mechanics the eye the maxwell
equations you can write also them with
ai and we are not confused but wait we
you and i are not confused but maxwell
was
and at the time of maxwell
there was a huge discussion what the
hell the maxwell equation mean
maxwell thought that this was an
effective description of a mechanical
more
gears inside the aether and trying to
make up with these mechanical models of
what happens inside
and it was very slow in fact it took
only the time of einstein i think so 40
years later
it became clear as a physicist said the
maxwell theory is just maxwell equations
namely forget the gears forget the ether
forget all that just keep the electric
field and magnetic field you don't need
anything else you don't even need the
space time in which they're sitting
that came with einstein general
relativity right so the discussion about
the interpretation of the maxwell
equation has happened
but we have converged
to one view i think if you and i sit
down and i think what is for you the max
equation and what i have for with my
equation we have the same intuition
we know what we're talking about maybe
we use different words but we we
understand one another
and it takes time it took it took 40
years the quantum mechanic is much more
radical to jump but i think we will end
up agreeing to a new vision of the world
and the maxwell equation changed our
picture of the world right before it was
particle with forces
and now after maxwell's fields where
this idea of fields it's a big jump
but the jump from
classical mechanics
things with property to quantum
mechanics relations between things is
much bigger
yeah and you mentioned uh that's
beautiful i always joke with people
imagine if twitter existed when maxwell
was coming up with his mechanical analog
so he would have said here are these
four equations and uh heavyside would
have you know promoted them and
everything is brilliant and then he
would have said and the interpretation
is gears and vortices and whirls and and
ether and people would have said ah
you're nuts crazy and they would have
thrown away maxwell's equations for 50
years or something like that so that's a
warning about twitter and about social
media and you stay away from it mostly
i'm more involved in it lately but uh
but i want to talk about social media
and this is provocative but uh but you
mentioned networks you mentioned
connections and the matrices of
heisenberg are another way of expressing
a network effect
so you can put the two particle
interactions but you could also have
your friends and my friends and we're
friends on facebook we're not friends on
twitter i don't know why but
i became a friend of you so immediately
to you
okay that was the thing that was a
shameless gravel for that okay but
imagine all of our friends my friends go
across the x-axis your friends grow
across the y-axis and then uh we look at
all the different pairs of combinations
right so that network because the matrix
is symmetrical you know what hap your
friend of my friend is the same as my
friend of your friend like that but um
but there's also an aspect of entropy in
other words the number of connections
grows as the number of particles or
friends squared so it grows very fast
but the cost kind of grows as the number
of friends like you don't have to
maintain like spend twice as much energy
when you have square root of two more
friends at it or whatever that means um
but there's so there's an aspect of
entropy there's more ways for you know
friendships to grow
and it made me think in your book of you
know maybe heisenberg actually did more
than he realized in other words there's
an entanglement once you have the matrix
you have an opportunity for entanglement
for entropy and uh and for things to
propagate at large distances uh unlike
schrodinger interpretation you don't
have that you don't have entanglement
inherently in it so i wonder is that an
aspect of superiority of the heisenberg
approach in other words that he
basically
appreciated and thought about things
like entanglement decades before it
became fashionable as it is now um yes
not because uh in in in destroying a
picture it cannot be done of course it
can be done because mathematically they
are equivalent
but because uh the schrodinger picture
um
based uh his uh it's uh sorry for the
ringing phone i'm not in my house i
cannot i cannot control it i hope the
body is gonna answer it
in the shredding a picture
the
the the fascination that the appeal of
the schrodinger picture is because it's
a function is a function in space
and the entanglement is that the reality
is not a function in space because it
has two legs in different points so in a
sense showing pictures that try to hide
it
and when you try to make it explicit and
make it details you get to many worlds
you multiply the worlds you make
you add a lot of stuff to reality well
in the in the heisman way of viewing
things
as you're saying it's just relation and
connection
and i think your your analogy is very
good because uh
i think it's the fact that the reality
is it's not properties of things but
it's connection between things
is a deep reason for which what counts
in reality is the complexity
you know combinatorial it's a it's
something absolutely incredible right
you you you know the
the fable of the king
um
to whom the wise men who invented czech
uh asked as a surprise to get one one
grain
in the first and then two and then four
and then okay
the king said of course is is easy and
then they do the calculation and all the
weight of the
of the empire was not sufficient for
that why because when you do exponential
the number go
super greatly so when you do
combinatorics number goes super greatly
and that's why reality is so complex
around us why is there well that's why
there are mountains and brain and and
animals and sea and and wind and trees
and galaxies
uh out of what out of electrons new
protons you know a few quarks just just
a bunch of things how can it makes all
that complexity
interactions
networks
that's what reality is it's a network
it's a complexity it's a richness of the
the way things
combine themselves not how things are
but how they get together
[Music]
that's so beautiful and i think about
that too when i think about my friends
that you know are more hermits and
isolated maybe they don't want families
maybe they don't want to you know find a
find a partner you know i think well
again the number of connections the
combinatorics explodes faster than the
cost increases you know in other words
if you have two kids and then you have
three kids you don't need another house
you can live in the same house hopefully
but the number of connections between
the two of them and the three of them
and the four and all of you together
that grows exponentially fast as you
just pointed out i think that's
beautiful and so i use that to advocate
for for bigger families bigger
friendships and uh and it doesn't even
have to be uh biological i feel
connected to you as we're gonna get into
instead of fighting one another and say
oh that country is becoming too powerful
is our adversary our enemy
let's make connections it's better
absolutely and the most impressive
beautiful quantum device ever invented
is our brain right as our is whatever's
happening in our brain which you touch
upon in consciousness in this book i
never like to give the end of the book
away but it is so beautifully written
it's such poetry as well and i think
that applies you know there's always an
old joke that my colleagues will talk
about oh we want to teach you know
physics for poets and i actually taught
a class with a pulitzer prize-winning
poet ray armentrout and she and i taught
uh poetry for physicists because i think
they need some of this they need the
shakespeare they need the tempest they
need to be the feeding of the soul for
what else is there uh as you say too
short the life and and for me to think
about you know what invests the quantum
mechanical reality with meaning it's the
human connections and so therefore i
salute this wonderful book uh called
helgeland the story of one of the most
delightful mysterious episodes in cosmic
history that led to a revolution in our
understanding uh carlo thank you for
coming on to talk about this wonderful
new book thank you very much
any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
you